our economies are so intertwined that
it's not possible for the president
united states to be
holding the line with china where it's
just difficult to put your foot down
with china because apple
could get crushed if they had to uh
you know weren't able to make more
iphones in china right
um i mean i i totally agree with you
that i think that surprisingly china's
actually been able to get off the hook
really easily considering that um you
know considering the
degree of destructiveness that this
pandemic has cost in terms of lives in
terms of um economic output
i i do think that this is something that
governments should not let go we should
demand legitimate answers and uh
inquiries into the origins of this virus
to make sure that it never happens again
to make sure that we fully understand
how this virus works how it came about
into being
um and and you know it is perfectly
reasonable for the world to get answers
to these things uh and i don't think
that the us government or any government
should uh let china get off the hook so
easily i mean i do think that um
obviously you know you pointed out the
really important issue which is that we
have a lot of large companies that are
very uh economically intertwined in
china that is kind of the main
um lever that china has uh that china
you know has hanging over our heads and
that is something that we should
absolutely be working to address and
i've you know as i write in the book i'm
very much in favor of an outbound cities
framework whereby
um the same way that the u.s government
can review
for on grounds of national security
inbound investments into into the united
states i think the us government should
be able to conduct similar reviews on
outbound investments from the united
states into foreign countries especially
china
on grounds of national security because
the billions of dollars that have been
poured from american companies into
china are now creating a lot of really
complicated national security issues for
the us
uh certainly you did not anticipate
uh i don't think anybody did
that
xi jinping would
uh
neuter
their own
technology companies that were
the amazing
crown jewels in a way of this china
renaissance whether it's you know
alibaba and jack ma or
you know 10 cent were the education
companies and here we have
uh xi jinping
come in and decapitate all these
companies send
jack ma to go do oil paintings on an
island somewhere like literally
that's what they said he's doing his oil
painting um
i think he might be in a re-education
camp but
they have essentially consolidated power
and at the same time we had people in
new york times telling us
when you and i and other folks who might
be a little bit more pragmatic about
this hey we shouldn't have tick-tock in
this country we had people at the new
york times saying oh you're being
hyperbolic oh you know we shouldn't
worry about tick-tock oh there's no
evidence that the chinese government has
control of these companies and was like
are you people dumb like it's an
authoritarian country of course they
have access to this
not only do they have access to it
they've just taken over the entire
private sector this would be as if biden
or trump decided they would be running
spacex tesla amazon google and facebook
in the same month and all of those ceos
just disappeared
yeah maybe you could comment on how
nobody saw that coming and what it
actually represents why is yin ping
doing it
it is
wild um
and i think one to ten wild
i mean it's really really why it's not i
mean it's not quite to me it doesn't
rise to the level of china is about to
declare war on taiwan in terms of the
repercussions for americans but um it's
wild in what it reveals about the
chinese system and what's going on
inside of the country and so
i think that you know the interesting
thing is i've spoken with a few of my
friends that work in in the intelligence
community and
i don't think there's anyone in the us
uh anywhere that ultimately a
characteristic of an authoritarian
government is that uh knowing why they
did this is really about knowing why xi
jinping did this it's about knowing the
intent of a single person and nobody in
the us really knows what his motives
were
but what we do know is what is the
impact of what he did and so we know
what the effect was and what the effect
is that it was a massive consolidation
of power and so to me what that says is
this was you know xi jinping an autocrat
that saw an alternative power base
forming inside of china where you had
very very powerful
you know uh celebrity pop culture
phenomenons in these tech companies and
their ceos um that he felt threatened by
and at the end of the day
uh it you know with xi jinping all roads
lead back to power and control and this
was just you know yet another
manifestation of that the other was it a
mistake
it's going to be like a big mistake on
this part yeah yes i think it is i think
this i think this is an example of how
we're seeing china starting to repeat
some of the self-destructive habits of
past
dictatorships when they grow paranoid
they start to go after you know all
their industries i mean for a long time
the chinese miracle
was justified by wow they have an
autocratic government but men the trains
run on time they're capitalists you know
they yeah pro business
things are really booming in china now
it's really just becoming you know uh
vintage circa dictatorships from you
know soviet style and
uh you know he's uh he as you point out
he basically nationalized um
an entire swath of its economy he's you
know now if you're a chinese
entrepreneur uh if you want to start a
company this has changed what success
looks like it's like success is no
longer i want to be the next jack jack
ma success is
uh if i'm really if i'm too successful i
might end up in jail so right so it's
you know i think it's it's really kind
of changed yeah it's a fine line it's
changed the basic bargain
of chinese society in a lot of ways and
how is it changing people wanting to
invest there we saw sequoia capital uh
and before them uh
idg pat mcgovern was the first venture
capitalist there really in the 80s and
then shortly after that sequoia other
folks coming into china having
incredible returns incredible runs
are private equity public market
investors venture capitalists
going to form new funds to address china
or are they going to be wrapping up shop
at this point
um i think the pictures mixed i mean i
think you have some investors that are
looking at that and that are being
really very realistic about the fact
that the u.s china relationship is in
the next five years is gonna go south
it's not gonna get any better and that
is just the reality
and there's no exit ramp here there is
no exit ramp for the next five years for
um unless you have and i've been saying
this for over a year now unless you have
structural changes on the part of how
the ccp operates we are not going to see
an easing of tensions
until
structural things take place and so if
you're a realistic investor
you may want to limit your exposure to
that with that being said china is very
very clever about wanting to
deliberately you know for them every
time an american investor puts money in
china it's another lever that they have
hanging over the us so for them they
want to attract as many
you know american dollars as possible
when you are trying to grow a startup
fast hiring engineers will slow you down
like nothing else don't i know it so
many companies i invest in are telling
me they can't get their next version out
because they don't have a great engineer
well lemon.io will find you a perfect
candidate in just 48 hours it's a
marketplace of engineers from europe and
they test and interview every developer
to eliminate the risk of a failed
project lemonio is the perfect solution
if you are a technical co-founder and
you need to delegate some of your
important tasks or you have a project
that needs specific technology and you
don't have that skill on your team yet
or you are just growing so fast that you
need to add more developers and get more
done faster they'll match you with a
candidate within 48 hours and if it
doesn't work out they'll replace the
developer right away so here is your cta
the old call to action if you could use
a full-time or even part-time developer
to run your projects faster go to lemon
dot io slash twist once again lemon l e
m o n dot i o slash twist and you'll
receive a 15 discount for the first four
weeks of work with that amazing
developer well done lemon okay check it
out everybody lemon dot io slash twist